um wow it's loud
wow
um okay hi everyone so i'm going to
um talk about work it's actually based
on a sequence of papers um
the most recent with
so there's been a lot of introduction uh
that's been really helpful by arnob in
the morning and from other things so
i'll just skim through this very quickly
um we have bayesian networks uh there
are visible variables always called v
and they could be all kinds of
configurations but for the purpose of
this um talk um there's we're going to
have in mind the situation where there's
just a hidden a single hidden variable
uh you
and the structure of the network in
general could be all kinds of things
that you saw in our knob stocks you gave
a bunch of uh examples and yuval will
develop that uh more thoroughly more
extensively in the in the lecture to
come
so i'm i'm really going to say actually
virtually nothing about this about
about causality in the structure of what
happens in the causal network in this
talk because that will come up in the
in the subsequent talk the notation i'm
going to be using for out throughout the
talk today is just this uh p
is the distribution the the visible
distribution so with the distribution
induced on on the uh
visible variables v
and this is what you would learn from
the data p of course is markovian on the
graph so it could be expanded always as
the product lowercase is going to mean
some assignment of the product over
vertices so the probability they take
this
value conditioned on their
parents
and this list of conditional
probabilities this is these are the
parameters of the model
so um
the
identification problem or parameter
learning problem it's sometimes called
is something like this you're given the
distribution to all the variables in
order that you're given
the distribution even including hidden
variables weren't hidden you could
easily identify the parameters the model
and easily here is um
at least it's at least it's uh it's
logically easily and arnhem was talking
about you know the statistical issues
could be non-trivial but but the the the
logical side of this is quite easy
um what if you are actually only given p
uh or an empirical approximation there
too on the visible variables what can
you determine
and uh part of the beauty of this theory
is uh
is that there is this uh amazing
algorithm which some of the contributors
are here in the room
um where
you know you could that exactly
determines all possible uh effects which
are
do affecting which are in fact implied
by by the uh by the by the data
the thing is that of course uh and i'm
sort of beating a tired horse here i
think after arnhem stoke is that you
know sort of in most cases
you can't do this you know you really
need a lot of sparsity you really need
these assumptions to hold very strictly
and so forth and that's kind of part of
uh what's hard here
and so um
you know
in this case in this graph you can
figure out p of v3 do uh v1 in this in
this graph you certainly cannot um and
in fact in this graph since the hidden
variable
broadcasts to all other variables so all
of them could be affected by this latent
in fact this hidden variable could
generate any probability distribution on
the graph there need not be any
signal
signaling carried by the directed edges
at all it could be just that the hidden
variable is completely dictating what's
happening in the network and you just
have this illusion that there's
something causal happening but in fact
uh it's all being handled by by the the
man behind the curtain
i've
okay so
um you can generate any distribution but
this requires and here's where we're
looking to kind of break some of these
assumptions not break but add to our
assumption list a little bit so we can
make some things possible that otherwise
are not possible
in order to do that you actually need to
range over a very large set so if there
are n variables here and also throughout
this talk that these variables are
binary
then in order to really dictate just an
arbitrary probability uh uh distribution
there you would have to range over a set
of size two to the n where n is the
number of variables okay so that's kind
of a very extravagant cost and so the
hope is that by
not being so extravagant by placing some
limitation there you might actually be
able to learn some things that you
otherwise cannot
so this kind of
cardinality or dimension bound is
is uh
you know it's actually a really kind of
long-standing assumption in various
areas i just don't think it's been been
done here um
uh and
we're going to
let kay throughout this talk be the
cardinality you know be the range of you
for the number of values that you can
take on
we're going to ask ourselves what can we
do
and we're going to be interested in
actually a hierarchy of three problems
of increasing generality
um as follows so
this problem i'm going to describe over
here is going to be the uh the k
k mix prod so that means it's a mixture
of uh product distributions where the
mixture has k mixture components so u is
picking out the mixture component
conditional on you the values at these
vertices are of course independent as
indicated by this graph
okay so there's no further structure
beyond what's carried uh there's no uh
by the by the by the unknown value of
this this latent so it's a mixture of k
uh
product distributions k-mix prod
and that's a special case of sort of
more general things that will that yuvaa
will talk about in this talk which are
what's the what happens when you have a
mixture of k
more general distributions and i'll
leave that for later so these are the
two
more ambitious problems that um well
we're going to be mostly uh that i'll
focus mostly on this one you've almost
seen on this one but let me mention a
simpler problem which is already um
turns out to be interesting and turns
out to be necessary for the
uh
for our work which is uh the k-mix iid
so k-mix iad is a special case of the
k-mix product but it's just a special
case where each of these
these variables vi
um
they're not just independent uh
conditional on the latent but they're
even or they're also identically
distributed condition
okay so it's an extremely
morally simple model but very few
parameters but it's a it's um turns out
to be a really important problem to
think about
okay so in this lecture i'll just talk
about these two problems
the plan for the lecture is like this
um first i'll talk for a little while
about this very kind of conceptually
easy problem or relatively simple
problem kmxid it turns out to actually
have a little more interest than you
would maybe suspect if you haven't
thought about these things before i'll
tell you about this wonderful uh
algorithm prony well i won't actually
have time to do it but if
you can do it on the side i'll talk
about ankle matrices and then uh
i'll mention one result which um goes
back about eight years that we proved uh
is a sample complexity lower bound on
this problem
um
that would puts it into the this
complexity and
you know
so for kmxiid we have a really good
lower bound and then we also um have a
upper bound through this algorithm
so i'll establish some base there and
then the second part of the lecture
maybe more of the lecture is going to
focus on this more general problem k-mix
prod
and i'll tell you about two concepts
that are important there one algorithmic
concept is this method of synthetic bits
and one the kind of more analytic uh
thing i want to tell you about is these
matrices we'll call hadamard extensions
which are somehow a multivariate
generalization
of uh vanderbilt matrices in the ankle
matrices which are the role
and we'll give you um an almost matching
upper bound to match the lower bound for
this simple problem we'll get the uh
almost matching uh upper bound
for the more general problem okay that's
right
so uh what's
what can we what's the story with k-mix
iid so knxiid is intimately related to a
classical problem and analysis uh known
as the moment problem
um where you have um
well let me start from here so you after
all is distributed on
you know these k possibilities according
to some
prior pi that you don't know
and we're just again for this lecture
focusing just on the case that the vi's
are all binary which means that for each
vi
and actually there's only a single one
because they're identically distributed
there's just this probability
that v sub i is equal to
one
given that
you know
given each of the k values that you can
take on right so depending on the value
of little u
there's a probability m sub u that this
variable is equal to 1. since they're
conditionally independent the
probability that if you have some set
capital r of these variables the
probability that they're all equal to
one is just m sub u to the power r
and so if you write down the number of
think of the ones as heads uh constantly
heads if you write down y as just the
number of heads that you see
then the moment so this is now an
integer valued random variable and its
moments are linear combinations of the
moments of what i'll call this case
spike or
atomic uh distribution so it's a
distribution on the unit interval which
has uh which has support uh finite
support cardinality k and it's just the
sum of these k delta functions uh
they're weighted by the prior and
they're the these sort of spikes the
atoms are at the locations according to
these these distributions okay so this
would be a two spike distribution it has
a certain amount of weight
at uh 0.1 another certain amount of
weight
0.9 spike distribution and the point is
that um
the
the in this in our situation that we
care about in this model came excited we
care about the the kind of variables
that we're interested in are you know
why the number of heads it's it's all
exchangeable so the only thing that
matters is the symmetric function so you
just hear that
um but these moments are they're not
quite the same as but they're related by
a simple linear transformation to the
moments of this k-spike distribution on
the real line okay
so this means that if you want to learn
the chemical id problem you reduce it
somehow to just
learning a distribution on the real line
or in fact on the unit interval from its
moments okay so this is
a wonderful problem
i'll just mention for pedagogical uh
value sort of what's known about this
problem because
so these things have been worked out uh
if i'm if you're given the first
question you can ask is just if i'm
given the list of moments
are they in fact the moments of any kind
of distribution on the real line there's
a beautiful answer the answer is that
you write down those moments in this
in this symmetric matrix where the
moments appear on
these sort of anti-diagonals
and
there's such a probability distribution
exists if and only if uh for all values
of k right so this is actually an
infinite object if and only for all
values of k when you take this upper
left-hand corner it is semi-definite
okay
and the measure is also unique provided
the muse don't grow too fast but for us
that's going to be guaranteed because we
have a compactly supportive distribution
so
now that was true for any probability
distribution we're interested in this k
spike formulation so what's special in
the case spike formulation so the answer
is that you need exactly two k minus one
moments and then you don't need any more
that's if you just count degrees of
freedom you know that should be the
answer but it
takes uh
um
so you only need the number of visible
variables to be 2k minus one and uh
there's this amazing just wonderful
algorithm pronate 225 year old algorithm
that um tells you exactly how to work
this out it's it's very simple but it's
just wonderful
so i'm not going to cover that right now
unless somebody uh
insists
so this solves the kmxiid problem kind
of in principle
you know you have that you collect your
statistics you gather your moments and
you invert and you figure out what your
what your parameters of your model were
those m subu's and the prior
distribution pi
um that's if you live here
um
we didn't live there for too long
so um we actually need to control uh the
dependence also on sample size
um
so
it's been actually discussed for kind of
a long time this is where people mention
how you know prone's algorithm is very
unstable but uh i couldn't find any we
couldn't find any quantification of that
actually and so
um
that was the content of a lower bound
that we proved in 2014 and i'll just
mention it now so
i should say that if you want to
reconstruct the parameters of the
distribution
um there's an instability there's
inherent instability of the problem i
have these this k-spike distribution if
i bring two of those spikes arbitrary
close to each other i can't resolve them
okay so
there
the there's a there's a impli if you
want to reconstruct the parametric uh
reconstruction you depend upon that
separation parameter we'll call that
separation parameters zeta and we have
there's a lower bound in terms of that
separation parameter
so
um you require this your empirical
distribution to be within that zeta to
the power k
um
in order to even uh determine the
parameters at all even to within plus
minus uh one over k which is about as
course as you can ask for
since everything lives in the unit
interval
so there's an implied so so you must
have a
and the sample size is the same as one
over the distribution difference
distance and distributions basically
so uh so this gives us an exponent this
gives you an exponential lower bound on
the on sample size um for any of the
problems that we're talking about
because this is the easiest of the
family problems we're going to be
talking about in a minute
and then more
okay
that same paper that we wrote back then
also gave an upper bound of one over
zeta to the k squared but that's that's
been since improved and also um there's
more work and i'm not going to talk
about this on reconstructing things in
transportation distance uh and i'm just
going to set that aside and happy to
talk about it
um so i want to move on because i really
want to talk about the problem that's uh
the more interesting the more ambitious
problem of this kmx
problem
so
here's again the picture of the diagram
but now the v's
if you're if you've matched those off
the
wake up because now the v's have nothing
to do with each other there's no
exchangeability they're not
they're um so this is a model with more
parameters of course
so
you have a prior there's still a prior
pie on the hidden variable that's
unchanged
but now in order to fully describe the
the problem
the parameters of the problem
you have not
a row basically of biases but uh for
each ver for each uh visible variable
he has a bi you know he has a
probability of heads given each value of
the hidden variable so this gives you an
n by k matrix and again n is the number
of uh variables here four and and k is
to get the number of
hidden uh number of values taken by the
hidden variable okay so the input to the
problem the
the family parameters is that n by k
matrix and the prime
so there's been work of the on this of
course um the prior work mainly focused
on what's called learning rather than
identifying so i'll use those words so
for those who are not sort of in the you
know it's like secret handshake so um
not only that but not everybody agrees
on the handshake but like learning means
you know reproducing the distribu to the
distribution in some sense and
identifying means source identification
means parameter learning okay so um
so um that's kind of the code word here
and
identifying is a harder goal in a more
restricted set of circumstances okay so
in general you can't identify uh as i
mentioned
so so you have to be in sort of a nicer
region of parameter space which also
offers the opportunity for um
for uh faster runtime perhaps because
you don't actually have to run on all
the same inputs that you would have
before
and we're going to want to do that in
anywhere where there's a stable
invertibility guarantee so uh it has to
be something like this if the distance
uh between you know if two models
generate
sufficiently um
if they're if they're far if they're a
little bit away in parameter space then
they also have to gen generate
distributions that are recognizably away
from each other in the you know in the
distribution space in which you once you
observe okay this is this is the only
case where it makes sense to certainly
ask for
identification
so um
okay just you know people are worried
about parameter identification going
back a long way these are the references
i could find
um
identification for us is really the
right problem to worry about if you have
in mind some kind of causal
uh motivation in the back of your mind
that you're going to take this network
and then you know maybe intervene on it
or something so it seems like for our
purposes the right problem both of them
make sense obviously
there is tons of literature on
learning mixture models
not just in the continuous space where
there's probably a case where there's
probably even more literature but even
in the discrete space
there's a lot of literature
and i i i tried to cram
some fraction of that onto this slide
um
the
maybe the most um
relevant to us
is a line of work beginning with basic
foreign sewer
goldberg and goldberg and then
um there was a really important paper by
feldman o'donnell cervedio
uh in 2008 on learn
well a little bit earlier in the
conference version anyway on learning
these mixture models and then the most
recent uh on that is chanda muytra uh
who
improved the complexity there
so i just want this is all in the
context all these things are in the
context of learning
and i just want to say one thing about
that which is
what those algorithms have to do is they
have to do a certain grid again some
point you do all kinds of nice things at
some point you have to kind of do a
search you have to
grid space and kind of look at
some uh
search and uh that's expensive you know
i mean there's just uh that's kind of
expensive way to do things um
and it it's a big question to my mind
whether it's avoidable but it gives you
these kinds of complexities some
function of n
but then the main thing that because
we're really focused on this parameter k
is you get this uh exponential and k
cubed in those in those components
um
so
um
we're going to not to want to not pay
that kind of exponential kq
um and we you know we don't do it for
those learning but we can do that for
identification
so
um
we're going to study this kmx prod under
a zeta separation assumption it's the
same kind of assumption i wrote on a
previous slide it just now applies to
every variable individually so every
variable has to be basically sensitive
to the values of the hidden variable it
has no good to have an observable if
that observable is not sensitive to the
hidden variable it's not going to help
you to learn anything about the model so
it's kind of a thing so every one of the
variables we want to be sensitive it
turns out it's enough that enough of
them are but let's talk about that
it was shown um in a nice paper that's
completely algebraic uh just a few years
ago by thomas
ali um that this mapping from the model
to the uh you know to the distribution
space or to the moment uh
is uh injective so it's in other words
you have identifiability even if zeta is
equal to zero
okay which just means that you have
distinct values in each row of this
matrix
um so even then that's enough to
identify the model up to some obvious
symmetries like
relay variable
um
and it's clear that you need that um
even it's more general okay it was clear
in the iad case but it's also clear here
you could have two columns that are just
completely identical of course so
there were two variables of behavior
um
i mean sorry two assignments of the
hidden variable that are behaving
identically so you
so um it turns out that uh this
assumption is actually
more than is necessary so
spencer and i have a separate paper
showing
that identifying identifiability still
holds under more of a like a hole type
condition where you have enough
separations that's kind of an aside so
if you're if you're current i mean
you should not take if you're interested
in these things you should not take it
as like you know this is the kind of
world you have to operate in uh
there are better things we could do but
we don't understand the full range of
that and this other result that we have
is completely non-algorithmic as well
okay so i'm just going to keep talking
about the iron
okay so um these are really interesting
open problems to
so let me just uh
now focus for my remaining
[Music]
so for the remaining time um let me just
focus on like what our
algorithm is for this uh kind of model
okay
so
we're going to suppose we're so now we
have this k-mix uh product uh problem
um we're gonna suppose for what we do uh
for the rest of the talk that we have at
least uh three k minus three
uh of observable variables
you can do with less but you can do two
k minus one but then you pay in the run
time
so we'll assume we have three k minus
three and we're going to do what you
would hope we're going to identify the
model
um it's going to be within sum plus
minus epsilon of the of the true model
and the runtime is going to be sort of
as promised there's going to be this the
the exponent is just k log k
and uh with some low order uh other
stuff
so what's the main challenge in trying
to do an algorithm like this well
i i i think there's a there's like a
real basic
you know
conceptual challenge which is
how do you use uh
these observables that have kind of
nothing to do with each other in their
behavior right so beforehand we have
they were iid so there's kind of an
obvious variable i called it y was the
number of heads everything was
exchangeable so there was a symmetric
function so it was kind of an obvious
thing to to use
um
so it was kind of
clear what to do it was clear what
information you had at your disposal and
it translated into this one-dimensional
um kind of model
but now these variables behave quite
differently
and it's not clear how to aggregate uh
that information
so um
so for the purpose of um so there's a
nice way of doing that
and for the purpose of getting there i'm
going to introduce you to
um
this thing we're going to call the
hadamard extension of a matrix so
remember for the purpose i want to
remind you that
um
this little m here is always going to be
this n by k matrix basically the
parameter matrix that describes the
behavior of each individual variable
so now a little bit of definitions if i
have two row vectors so m1 and m2 would
be like the the first and second row
let's say of that matrix they're how to
mark product it's just a kind of the
pointwise product right so the youth
entry of the u remember is ranging from
one to k horizontally in the row the
youth entry of that row is the product
of those two numbers so that's the hud
of our product sometimes called sure
product usually
so what's the hadamard extension of this
n by k matrix it's the matrix i get by
doing this kind of operation across all
subsets
okay so the first row of the matrix
is where i took the empty set so the
first row of the matrix the hardware
extension is always just going to be all
ones because i took the empty set
and then i have a bunch of more rows
which are the original matrix where all
the singletons sets and then i'd start
having hardware products of pairs and i
i can i can i can any subset okay
so uh so i'll call this you know
blackboard h you know m sub s is the
capital s row out of these two to the n
uh
um
rows
okay so is it clear what the automotive
extension is here's an example i started
with a matrix m it has two rows
and i have here two to the two uh rows
with the empty set the original rows
and then their product
so
this matrix uh we're the ones called
hudamar extension but it already shows
up in the chen moisture paper that plays
a key role in that paper
so
why do we care about this matrix well
these are exactly the things that um
that give you you know observables
because what can you observe if you take
the hadamard matrix so it's this very
tall thing just 2 to the n by k
and if i just multiply it by
the column vector of the priors i'm
going to get this vector of length 2 to
the n
and those are exactly the observable
probabilities those are for every
subset of the variables the product that
they all the probability probability
they all come up heads everything in
that substance so this is exactly kind
of the information that you have access
to
is this column vector because you don't
know those two things
but this gives you a kind of a nice
understanding of what what you have
access to
so
although we
know the left-hand side but we don't
know this decomposition on the
right-hand side we're going to be able
to
uh still kind of get to
still use this
so it's so there's going to be two
things happening in the algorithm or the
work let's say
one is how to use it if you had it
perfectly
if you you had h of m let's say
perfectly um but then there's also the
question of how stable all these things
are under perturbation because we want
sample size bounds
so i'm actually going to kind of reverse
things and just tell you what the
stability results are first it's a
little more convenient and then tell you
after that what the algorithm is so
these are the kind of two main things
that we show
so
um
so the here's here's a a general lemon
condition number of huda mart extensions
um
it says
if i take any set of um
k minus one rows of m that are zeta
separated okay so these variables
they're all they're each they satisfy
this zeta separation condition
now
and i take and i form the automatic um
extension
uh just on that on that subset a okay so
this is m restricted to a i mean they
take those k minus one subsets i just
form the hardware extension of them so
it's going to have two to the k minus
one rows this matrix
then the least uh singular or the the k
singular value the the last one that's
significant
of this um how the mark extension is
singularly exponential in zeta okay
so that's
that lower bound is crucial that kind of
is going to translate very quickly into
a sample complexity
this is basically kind of a pretty far
generalization
of the stability results for the unit
for the not for the iid case the real
line case
um it's kind of a multivariate
generalization although i don't don't
pin me down how that
but
for what was crucial for the mixed id
problem was that there was a kind of
stability of the van der maan matrix
that translated the stability of the
heinkel matrix and here it's a very
similar story the stabili the stability
of the hadamard extension this stability
of the hardware extension is like
stability of the van dermont and it'll
translate into stability of another
matrix we'll see in just a moment that's
used yeah in the algorithm that's
kind of like a generalization of the
handkerchief
so um
there's another result i want to use now
to make the talk easier or this is not
actually how the algorithm best works
but uh there's a just a beautiful lemma
there uh also i'd like to show people
things that are really kind of
fundamental there's a beautiful llama um
by fellow donald soffario that says if
you have an r by k matrix it's r is at
least k
then
and you want to know and and and it has
substantial uh uh substantial singular
values so it has a lower balance on the
on the k singular value like like we
have here in the lemma three
then it's always possible to find a a
square sub matrix that also has a large
condition number okay this is not at all
obvious
um and it's a beautiful proof uh so
we'll just get it so one thing we can do
although it's not the best way to run
our algorithm and i'll but i'll talk it
through that way anyway
is uh pretending we did that and we're
just working with k by k matrices at
some point although that's not the best
way
so the current the corollary then is
that our matrix which we've just shown a
singular i'm sorry a
conditional rebound for or bound on the
case singular value
still has essentially has a k by k
symmetrics which essentially the same
guarantee on the singular value the loss
vector is trivial
so now
there's a different way of arranging
these values that these observables
instead of observing them in a long
column vector
we can actually form this matrix which
is
formed by taking the hadamard extension
and um you know it's column
times the diagonal the priors and then
hit again by the transpose of the
hadamard extension
but not all of this matrix is well
defined
because there are cases where you're
wanting to square you know some variable
but you can't square variable you only
see it once
so
um
part of this matrix is observable it's
first column for example is observable
because any place where the row set and
the column set or disjoint is observable
so
uh
if r and r prime have the empty
intersection then the c sub r r prime
entry is just the probability that all
the of those variables in that set
they're all uh equal to one
and if i take subsets a and b of the
observables that are disjoint then i can
observe the entire
kind of generalized tankle matrix
spanned with rows taken from a
and columns taken from b
so now i have this great big square
matrix
and i can have guaranteed through the
previous slide basically that each of
those contributions have have good
condition number and therefore also the
whole thing is going to have a good
condition number so we can form this
whole matrix
and give it a guaranteed condition of it
how do i use it so that was the kind of
stability the condition numbers stuff
that i want to talk about and the other
thing i want to tell you about before
the time my time is up
is
um the algorithm so we haven't said
anything about the algorithm and how it
is that we're going to aggregate
information from these completely
unrelated variables into some some kind
of thing and we are actually going to
reduce the kmx id so we are actually
going to reduce to the case where they
actually all the variables were iad how
do we do that so this is this method of
synthetic bits and similar ideas you
know just talking about some things so
um
so if you fix any two disjoint a and b
and you have this well-conditioned cba
um
you can uh
we we're going to we you see here i i
want to i want to synthesize a copy of
so i take my sets a and b and i have one
row i have one variable that's left out
i have enough variables so that uh i
have k minus 1 a in a k minus 1 and b
and then i have more variables left over
the worst case just one but in fact i'm
assuming i have even k minus 1 left over
and i want to mimic one the behavior of
one of those rows one of the ones i held
out
so what i do is i compute its moments by
passing it through
a
okay so the idea is here i can look i
can compute for example the expectation
of you know that first row by just
hitting this row m1 that describes its
parameters with the diagonal and then
just the all ones that's like the first
column of cba
and you know the way of thinking about
it in terms of synthetic variables i
wish i had another v1 prime variable
that was iid to v1
i don't
if i did i could compute this the
hadamard extension the hardware product
of m1 with itself times the same sort of
thing and that would give me the
expectation of u1 squared i don't but
i'm going to synthesize it
so the idea for synthesizing it is that
look this v1 vector this is a vector
this is a row vector
i is what i would get not by just
looking at the expectation of v1 that if
we go back to the previous slide that
was just like the first entry
but i can actually get the entire long
row here
and this
now i'm in a world where i'm full rank
so there's only sort of one way to get
v1 and i can synthesize a copy of it
by
mapping that vector back
under the inverse of cba getting a
family of parameters that synthesize a
copy of m1
and then mapping it forward
to uh to get uh this this v2 that i care
about
okay so that gives me the second moment
of one my rows so now it's as if i had
two id copies of that row
and i can keep doing this once i have
that vector for the second moment i can
carry it back get parameter get a a
synthetic representation of that
and then hit it again with v1 and keep
going forward backward and forward and
backward so that that
kind of zigzagging back and forth
uh lets me manufacture any moment that i
want the v1 as if i had a bunch of iid
copies of it
so i used 2k minus 1 times and then i
could just apply the k-max iab problem
so it's a crucial here that control the
operator norm of this inverse
it's crucial here to control the
operator norm of this inverse
we showed that that's bounded by zeta to
the k so if you do this operation i just
described you pay every time
and if you do it the way i just
described you're going to now
have you know kind of a composite
instability
your condition number of all these is
going to be one over zeta to the k
squared that was probably the thing i
would avoid
so now is the riddle to the audience
let's see the way around this
this is the part you leave for the
homework
so
you can do um repeated squaring
okay so i showed you how to get from a
first moment to a second moment and then
i went from the second to the third but
why should i go from the second to the
third i can go from the second to the
fourth this is why i need three k minus
three bits and not two k minus one
because i wanna i have to kind of do
this with two separate sets of so
okay
so um we can go from the first moment to
the second one to the fourth moment all
the way up to the 2k month one one
moment and then we only pay log then we
only pay for this condition number log
times
that proves the theorem that i promised
uh in terms of um future work
um we should definitely be doing this
problem also in transportation distance
just like we did for kmxiid one should
go definitely want to solve this
transportation cost there's a reasonable
uh
what exactly you want to achieve there
i'm not exactly sure but it's sort of
it's sort of a clear open problem that i
don't have not necessarily you know
state informally
um
but
the question there's a big question
there as i mentioned to you the
the feldmodal cervedio and the chin and
moisture paper still have this this k
cubed in the exponent
um
which is um pretty unpleasant given that
we only know exponential and k uh lower
bounds and um so the question of whether
that that could be done
uh there's a question of what uh again a
vague question where parametric models
you know
what's the equivalent of this kind of
results for parametric models
um and then what to do with multiple
confounders so i've been dealing with a
single cardinality battle confounder
what do you do with multiples
not really i don't i don't know a
beautiful um
um you know kind of like here's the
beautiful thing to do
there's a there's a really easy kind of
way around
just
partition you just partition whatever
sometimes you have treated with several
bits
um
it's kind of a
way of doing it um instead of autobot
extension you do get a natural algebraic
object which is now a tensor
so it's solvable but there's probably a
more beautiful solution
is there a connection to the kind of
work of people
is there a connection to the work of
people like elizabeth allman and john
rhodes on
the expression you had
with like the left side and then the
diagram pi
and then the right side it looks very
like a matrix flattening as they call it
so you sort of take
the states of some variables index the
rows and states of the other variables
and extra columns and then that matrix
has to have a low rank constrained by
the
so maybe this is what i don't know so
john rhodes and john rhodes
i think they're in alaska um
let's talk later
from hebrew university